le président je ne défends pas que le
football ne défend aussi le rugby je
tenais quand même à le à le dire parce
que ma première intervention n'était pas
complète sur ce point deuxièmement mes
chers collègues je vais exactement dans
votre sens et je me permets de vous
signaler que si vos amendements ont été
adoptés vous vous seriez tirer une balle
dans le pied tout simplement parce que
quand vous dites que la george doit être
proportionnelle à la capacité d'accueil
est que vous ne fixé aucune propension
le gouvernement aura les mâts
entièrement libre il pourra décider 5%
de la capacité d'accueil 10% 15% 20% il
fera juridiquement c'est obligatoire
exactement ce qu'il voudra donc les deux
amendements qui sont ainsi rédigé sont
des amendements qui donne les pleins
pouvoirs au gouvernement pour fixer
l'âge anges dans les stades aussi bien
pour le rugby que pour le foot bal donc
je voudrais vraiment insister sur ce
point vous avez présenté des amendements
qui sont moins contraignant pour le
gouvernement que la position que je vous
ai rappelé tout à l'heure qui consiste à
dire que on doit tenir compte des
risques de promiscuité en fonction de la
configuration et de la capacité
d'accueil du stade en cause quant aux
deux autres amendements qui fixent eux
mêmes une jauge je redis que fixer une
jauge dans la loi c'est une erreur car
ça aboutit nécessairement a traité de la
même façon le stade de rennes et le
stade de france alors qu'ils n'ont pas
la même capacité d'accueil j'insiste
beaucoup sur ce point en vérité quelle
que soit la mandement que vous voterez
et bien ou que vous ne voterez pas
plutôt ça n'est pas au coeur de notre
discussion législative mais ce que je
vous dis c'est dans l'intérêt même des
porteurs de ces amendements parce que je
voudrais que effectivement leur
intention trouve une traduction
efficiente efficace opérationnel dans la
loi et je trouve que la moins mauvaise
solution c'est quand même celle que nous
avons retenu aller contraignantes pour
le gouvernement
[Musique]